trevor rogers who makes his fourth start
this season
and uh i tell you what a lot of
strikeouts it's kind of been his mo
going back to his minor league days and
he is not disappointed and in steps the
leadoff hitter austin hayes this is a
ground ball to third john birdie over
there this afternoon he makes the play
one pitch and one out mancini batting
206 now with four home runs
left side birdie having a busy afternoon
ryan mout castle out in left field
hitting third
it's a little more fun to watch him
strike guys out he's got his first of
the afternoon bruce zimmerman to the
hill next off the left-hander bruce
zimmerman you see what he's done this
year he has been really solid for the
orioles has not given up more than three
runs in any of his three starts so far
jess chisholm is going to step into the
box and lead it off for the marlins jazz
chisholm junior has a base hit that's
what i was talking about see how it goes
because we know jazz just as a
personality kind of a spark plug and two
on nobody down and here comes jesus
aguilar
center field austin hayes is there
chisholm
wait a minute
runner on first base almost got hung up
now face left hand hitting corey
dickerson
got him
breaking ball severino hung on for the
third out pedro savarino a homer in one
rbi on the season 1-2 pitch swinging a
roller through the right side marlins
had shifted and three between second and
third aguilar was off the line but he
couldn't get there in steps
freddie galvez
freddie galvez waves and misses had a
change up a couple of strikeouts for
rogers ramon urias the second baseman
this afternoon all for one as a pinch
hitter last night
rogers with another strikeout that time
96. he's got three through two so an
infield hit for sandy leone first at bat
of the season this is a pitcher trevor
rogers
and he does
got him with a breaking ball
marlins down in the second no score ryan
mckenna listed number 22 prospect in the
oriole organization first ball hitting
sends a fly ball to brynson brinson
drifts back to right center pulls it
down one pitch one out first career
played appearance for bruce zimmerman
simplify the mechanics another strikeout
for rogers he's got four the first trip
through the order austin hayes grounded
out to third base in the first inning
and hayes into the lineup today shoots
one down the right field line he takes a
turn duvall's throw to miggy
[Applause]
the orioles might want to take a look at
it and they have motion for a review the
swim move
oh
that's close but duvall
wow what a throw
talk about putting the ball on the bag
they
say the call uh stands
aguilar hit a fly ball to center field
is only at bat to get him the right
spots bounce to short galves up with it
aguilera retired two down there's adam
duvall made that strong throw out right
field
one two
chased upstairs popped it up on the
infield
mancini calling
and makes the catch
so the marlins are down in the third
still zeroes on the scoreboard ray
mancini leading it off for the orioles
in the top of the fourth how about this
this was right here at lone depot park
jacob rogers had a sign he tweeted it he
said hey i've got a friend his name is
brad undergoing surgery for colon cancer
this week can you sign a ball for him to
give him a little extra encouragement
and hey mancini did just that so sending
best wishes to brad reed rooting for a
speedy recovery and hey what a good
friend jacob is that's gonna be a nice
surprise now here comes michael franco
he's 0 for one today
cuts and misses
and rogers has another strikeout picked
up a couple of strikeouts on the
changeup away today galveston franco
mount castle in scoring position 0-1
to pedro severino who lifts one out to
left field for
dickerson that'll do it
bottom of the fourth coming up brenson
popped up to severino
and his only at bat
bounced up the middle should be two
and there it is here's john bertie
there's the change up
severino have to throw down to first and
he does it's a strikeout for birdie
freddie galvez will start the inning off
against rogers
here's the swing of a line drive into
right down on one bounce in front of
duval so 02 but he missed his spot
centered in the middle of the plate and
freddie galvez has his ninth hit of the
road trip so now ryan mckenna will bat
another strikeout for trevor rogers he's
got six
and there are
two away here in the fifth zimmerman
struck out in his first big league at
bat rogers ready here's the pitch check
swing did he go around yes he did inning
over that was a fastball at 92 upstairs
sandy leone will get ready to bat for
miami
[Applause]
yeah another sharply hit ball by leon
and he's got himself a couple of hits
called up today to replace alfaro and he
is two for two trevor rogers is going to
be asked the bunt he does have one
sacrifice this season
rogers lays it down franco thought about
second instead would flip to first and
now a foot race to the third base bag
everybody's gonna get there but leon
gets there first
rojas has walked so now with runners on
the corners aguilar will bet
this one out toward the gap in left
center gonna get down and jesus aguilar
has extra bases this is gonna score two
and it gives the marlins a lead here in
the fifth inning
that's the hit they needed
marlins finally break through
elevated fastball
aguilar finally got himself one i told
you 88 of the time you're going to see
zimmerman try to elevate with the
fastball with two strikes
adam duvall with an opportunity to add
to this two-run inning
line base hit into left field aguilar
rounding third he's going to score and
duvall
adds to his team leading rbi total it's
three nothing
now trevor rogers has an opportunity to
win this sucker one two three do up ball
is hammered line drive to his left rojas
dives and makes the catch a terrific
play by miguel rojas to start this top
of the sixth inning hayes hit it hard
right into the shift and rojas had to
lay out to his left nice play trey
mancini
that one not in play another strikeout
for rogers he's got eight two down and
raymond aria so bad
this is jazz at the second base bag
and trevor rogers is the first marlin to
complete seven innings of work this year
here's miguel rojas
lined into the glove freddie galvez with
a diving grab and flips it behind his
back that is robbery right there brady
galvez then flashing some leather as of
late watch this play 105 off the bat boy
you're talking about barreled up ready
for that tour
a fly ball to right a strikeout and a
double
chopped up the middle
jazz is there over to first it's a
marlins win
three-nothing the final this afternoon
marlins get the split against the o's
before heading west